welcome back America's Got Talent Live
is a celebration of Comedy music danger
dance and so much and things are
actually a little extra spicy right now
as psychic comedian Peter Antonio he's
as taken over as guest host of the show
and he's here with us now thanks for
being here man thank you for having me
Jason you're kind of doing double duty
because you're performing in the show
and you're guest hosting what's it like
guest hosting the show um it's so it's
so much great fun I get to like
introduce all of the acts to the to the
audience and like bring them into the
AGT world because we spend so long with
all these incredible acts and it's nice
to be able to introduce the audience to
them and remind them of some of their
favorite acts and get them to experience
it in a live format as well because it's
different when you're just watching it
on television as opposed to when it's
just in front of you is there outside of
your own Act is is there a standout act
that you look forward to seeing every
night oh there's so many of them I love
watching um deadly games they sort of
they throw knives at each other every
night okay every night my my heart's in
myself I'm thinking oh God like I hope
that it doesn't go wrong and every night
you sort of pinpoint accuracy never
misses
and it's a family friendly show right
yeah family friendly so it's great for
the whole family we've got such a great
range of Acts that you know from the
youngest kids to grandma can all enjoy
the show and get involved it's kind of
extra special this week because a lot of
families are in town for Thanksgiving
and after Thursday night Thanksgiving
you're looking for something to do come
down and see you guys uh in the whole
show what was it like actually
performing on live television for you
um it was it was weird like I'm the
person who's like just nervous all the
time in actual life like on live
television I just felt really calm
because it's like it's my wheelhouse I'm
reading Minds I just felt really
comfortable
um and even Simon Cowell scowling at me
didn't quite put me on well let's uh
before we wrap up here because you have
some Mind Tricks mind reader list can we
do something here forever try something
okay do you have a passcode on your
phone they do okay right just think of
your password and you've not like had
your phone out you're working it's sort
of presumably okay just focus on
the first digit of your passcode is that
a one yes it is yeah good okay and
genuinely like you've not told me this
we've not set anything up this is just
um it's a year isn't it yes it is this
year someone was born no it's not oh no
no okay I don't want to put your whole
number on blast so what I'll do is I'm
going to write this down on my hand and
just show it to you you have to promise
to be honest if I'm wrong I'll take the
girl is that your passcode no you're
wrong I'm wrong you're wrong you're
close close is that that last digit is
that the one it's the last digit Oh no
you're right yeah you're right yeah I
wasn't sure yes oh my gosh mine but I'll
say what it is it's just my phone he's
sure everyone it's 1992. here's the
thing though you wrote 1997 which is my
other go-to passcode 92 I graduated from
high school I know how to look it 97 I
graduated from college that is crazy
okay because it felt like you were
flipping between two numbers so it sort
of threw me off but that makes sense I
meant I graduated from college in 2002
92 which is a special year to me good
and now just think
uh now through Sunday over at the Luxor